Chase is with us in Meridian Mississippi
hey chase how are you thank you it how
about you today better than I deserve
what's up and nothing nothing I've
started listening to you about I guess a
month and a half ago and I listened to
you about three hours a day
Wow I think you hold the whole entire
podcast my question is is I'm a painter
right now I've done a lot of tours old
and I've worked in tightening
construction just about my whole working
career as far as lawn care service I've
done that since I was about 16 on my by
myself and I've never made a bunch of
money because I've never worked for a
big company so we might work seven
months out of the year and be off there
the other five now I'm fixing to go back
to school and and to be a paramedic and
I've got a yard care service didn't
after I get out of school and our
paramedic which would you recommend
growing that into a bigger company while
I'm a paramedic
absolutely and keeping it while you're a
paramedic right absolutely has a lot of
fire folk work 72 long 72 off alright
that's about the same with with them
what about an EMT yeah so that gives you
the it gives you an excellent
opportunity for a wonderful side
business I know a lot of firemen around
the u.s. that I have lawn care companies
have painting companies they have all
kinds of different things like that I
know one guy makes a good living
building decks alright he's a bit of a
deck artist actually but anyway you can
do all kinds of stuff you know with that
with that schedule that you've got and
another thing I'm just I I called
because I don't nobody in my family has
been an entreprenuer and they've always
worked for somebody my dad works I'm
sorry right there's a driller on an oil
rig my stepmom she's are in and and they
bet they don't approve of the Dave
Ramsey type deal they're half a million
dollars in bed and probably don't make
two hundred thousand so I just wanted I
just wanted a little piece of advice and
and also one more quick thing they
they they were going to pay for my
college just out of the greatness of the
heart to help the son but they just
recently purchased the house and now
either I'm gonna have to figure out how
to cashflow my college fund or I'm gonna
have to do the student loan
well you're going to cashflow it well
right right right but the thing is is
the paintless slow right now
and I'm making with my yard care
business arranging worth from seven
hundred a month to about twelve hundred
that's what that I've abused and and a
painting it's been shot for about a
month well then then you know you got a
look at what you can do short term to
get some cash rolling and are you're
single
does that mean heading off and working
somewhere where construction is booming
for three months so you can make a pile
of money working 80-hour weeks and then
come back and go to school all right
something like that I don't know but you
just got to change your plan because you
don't have enough coming in to cash flow
life much less cash flow calling or EMT
school and so we get your income up
somehow so either we do something
besides lawn care and painting or we you
know we take a little time off let
somebody pick up your yard schedule for
you and you take off and go somewhere
and work your tail off and when these
boom towns right now and believe me
construction is booming in a bunch of
cities to the point that people are
making Bank because they can't get
people to show up so you can't find work
out there right now in that field you're
something wrong with you so but in your
case I'm not saying I'm saying in a town
where their stuff booming and I don't
know what it what Meridian is doing one
way or the other but I mean you take a
Nashville in Atlanta Dallas a Charlotte
if you can't find construction work by
nightfall something's wrong with you so
you're not looking just people we can't
the subs are not showing up there
they're late everything it's just a
disaster a labor shortage so anyway it's
causing wages to shoot up in these boom
construction cities so anyway that's
something you can look at I don't care
if you do it there Meridian you do it
somewhere else but we need to figure out
a different strategy that gets you
ultimately plugged into
you know being able to finish EMT and
get that part of your income then
stabilized while you build your business
on your off days and you could build up
a really nice income between those two
things as being your career track and
kind of have a nice variety in a given
week so hey cool man thanks - good to
talk with you if I can help you further
you call me anytime hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show you can do this you
know that really is a message whether
you've got two hundred seventy thousand
dollars in student loan debt or 27
thousand well you've got a fifty
thousand dollar income or $500,000 in
economy